عندما تستخدم وسائل النقل في باريس اول ما
عليك فعله وابقاء عينك على اغراضك الشخصيه
عباره شائعه يسمعها السياح كنصيحه عند
قدومهم الى هنا نظرا لارتفاع معدل السرقات
خاصه في محطات مترو الانفاق القريبه من
يزور باريس حوالي 50 مليون سائحا سنويا
ويستخدم معظمهم مترو الانفاق لانه الاسهل
للوصول الى المواقع السياحيه وهذا ما
تفعله جوردن خلال تجولها في المدينه لكن
خوفها الدائم من التعرض للسرقه يعكر عليها
صفو رحلتها خاصه انها عاشت التجربه سابقا
مخيف لقد حدث معي مره وهو يغير قليلا من
نظرتنا لباريس يشعرنا بعدم الامان فهو
يعني انه في اي وقت قد نتعرض للسرقه هذا
سيء للغايه بالنسبه للاجانب الذين ياتون
لزياره اجمل مدينه في العالم انه حقا امر
مزعج هنا في جاده الشانزليزي ينظم فيليب
حركه الحافلات السياحيه في باريس ويتعاون
مع الشرطه في حال تعرض احد السياح للسرقه
على متن الحافله
افراد الشرطه متواجدون في المناطق
السياحيه بكثره سواء هنا بجده شونزيليزي
او بكنيسه السيده العذراء او متحف اللوفر
وبرج ايفل
تفاقمت ظاهره السرقات في السنوات الاخيره
وباتت تهدد صوره السياحيه لباريس ويبدو ان
جاذبيه اجهزه الهواتف الذكيه كون وغيرها
تقف وراء ارتفاع معدل السرقات سيسيل سائحه
من الجزائر تعلمت من خطاء اختها الا تترك
فرصه للسارق كلمه فعلا المترو غير امن
شخصيا لمواجه تجربه السرقه ولكن اختي سرق
هاتفها في المحطه خلال ثوان معدوده عندما
كانت تقطع التذكره ولم نستطع معرفه السارق
وتشير دراسه اصدرتها الداخليه الفرنسيه
بالمقارنه بين 2008 و2018 الى ان نسبه
السرقات المعلن عنها في وسائل النقل العام
ارتفعت من
33% الى 42% زينه عدي العربيه باريس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات